a star-spangled sky is a truly amazing
and tremendous sight
these lights twinkling in the night have
charmed humans since
times a memorial and inspired them to
dream
and strive for new discoveries however
there are places in our galaxy where the
star count in the sky is several times
higher than that in the earth's sky
these aren't the dim and cool lights
we're used to seeing either
but an exceptionally dazzling multitude
of large stars
it is hard to imagine what it looks like
but this is what the universe appears to
be
seen from the center of one of the
largest superstar clusters
in our galaxy westerlund one
[Music]
a star cluster is a group of stars which
formed from one in the same gigantic
cloud of
interstellar mata these stars are
practically identical
in terms of their chemical composition
and age the system they form is bound by
gravity forces
star clusters fall into either of these
two categories
which are the main varieties open and
globular clusters
open star clusters are products of
stellar nurseries evolution
the latters are areas of cosmic gas
where stars are actively born
that is why the clusters here are mainly
comprised of young stars and great
amounts of interstellar hydrogen
gravity forces between them are
comparatively feeble
which leads to an open cluster's
disintegration several hundred million
years
after its formation which of course is
mere seconds in astronomical terms
some of its former members still stick
together in their joint movement
in space thus forming a stellar stream
while others
break away from their group to become
soul masters of their own destiny
over 1 100 open star clusters have been
pinpointed in our galaxy
and incidentally it appears to be just a
tiny portion of their overall count
globular clusters are larger and denser
than open ones
and consist of old and not very massive
stars
the average distance between the stars
there is 4 to 6
light months as for their masses these
may reach a million times that of the
sun
the milky way contains not less than 150
star clusters of this type
and the andromeda galaxy over 500
open clusters are comparatively modest
in size
but the star count in some of them
reaches thousands
these objects are referred to as
superstar clusters
the largest of them are thought to
eventually turn into globular ones
all it will take is waiting around for a
few billion years or so
until the most massive stars there have
burned out and
exploded one of the largest
superstar clusters in our galaxy is one
referred to
as westerland one it was spotted back in
1961 by swedish astronomer banked
westerland
but for a long while remained largely
understudied as it is quite difficult to
observe
the distance from the cluster's center
to the solar system has been estimated
at approximately 10
000 to 15 000 light years staggering
though this figure may
seem westerlund 1 is in fact one of our
closest
superstar clusters that is why it is
crucial to observe it
to bring our understanding of stellar
evolution processes to a whole new level
the diameter of westerland one measures
around seven light years
astoundingly this area which is really
tiny in astronomical terms
is literally crammed with thousands of
stars with a total mass of about 63 000
solar masses some straightforward
calculations
show the distances between the major
members of the cluster
are just several light months as for
binary system components
they are much closer to each other than
that due to incredible density of the
stars in the cluster
and the clouds of interstellar gas the
stars are shrouded in
it is impossible to distinguish the
exact sources of light here
as the thousands of stars this light
comes from are too densely packed
this greatly interferes with
observations and doesn't allow the
observer to count the stars
that is why the exact stark out and
westerland one
remains to be gauged among them the
following types of stars have already
been pinpointed
six yellow hyper giants four red
supergiants
twenty-four wolf react stars and a super
giant with a highly peculiar emission
spectrum
supposedly it formed on collision of two
massive stars
in addition there is a great number of
hot blue giants and an x-ray pulsar
discovered among the stars in the
cluster
the pulsar is an anomalous object a
neutron star
spinning with a mind-boggling spade the
binary star count is also quite high in
westerland westerland1
this fact may be accounted for by the
high density of the clusters objects
all the superstar clusters objects are
posited to have formed at round one at
the same time
however depending on the type of stars
they differ
in terms of their rage too to start with
according to today's theory of stellar
evolution red
supergiants cannot be younger than four
million years
wolf rayet stars on the other hand which
are in the final stage of their life
cycle by definition are remarkably
numerous in the cluster
their life expectancy is known almost
never to have been over
5 million years thus the age of
westerlund 1
is quite accurately estimated at a mere
four to five million years
which in essence is seconds in
astronomical terms
at approximately the same time it was
forming first australopithecus
and sabretooth tigers roamed the earth
and all that had been left of dinosaurs
by then
was just their fossilized remains
mathematical modelling of the cluster's
formation shows
that the cluster may have contained 50
to 150 heavy stars
that would have depleted their resources
by now and so would have come to the
final stage of their life cycle
given the estimates are correct on
average there would have been supernovae
every 10 000 years in the course of the
past million years
as we know the heavier a star the faster
it comes to the end of its life cycle
and goes supernova
after which it leaves a black hole
neutron star or white dwarf
however to date only one object like
that has been detected
it is thought that many supermassive
stars would have turned into black hills
but these are rather difficult to spot
today
the superstar cluster westerland one
contains one of the largest stars known
today
designation westerlund 126
since it is rather difficult to observe
it its radius has been gauged at roughly
1500
to 2500 times that of the sun
if its radius is closer to the bigger
margin
westerland 126 may be the biggest star
known to mankind however the radius is
more likely to lie closer to the lower
margin
and measure slightly over 1 500
times that of the sun even so
if its center were to be theoretically
placed in that of the sun
westerland 126 would cover all the
planets
reaching as far as the orbit of jupiter
the supergiant's luminosity is
approximately 380
000 times that of the sun although its
surface temperature is comparatively low
just around 3 000 kelvin the star's mass
hasn't been gauged yet
but today's perception of stellar
evolution allows us to assume that it
may be around
20 solar masses another unusual object
in the cluster is a magnetar with a name
like a tongue twister it is also the
most
powerful source of x-ray radiation in
that area of space
located approximately 16 000 light years
from the sun
it is a neutron star whose rotation
period
is about 10 seconds incidentally this is
rather slow in comparison to other
objects of this class
those rotate several times a second
given that all the stars in the cluster
formed at around one at the same time
it would have taken the star that was
the progenitor of this magnetar
just five million years to deplete its
thermonuclear fuel
this means that when it was born its
mass should have been not less than
40 solar masses however in that case it
should have left a black hole
rather than a neutron star after going
supernova
it transpires that the progenitor star
had to unaccountably lose up to 95
percent of its mass
before going supernova one of the
possible answers to this riddle
may lie in the fact that the object may
have originated from a binary star
rather than a single one by spinning
around their common mass
center at an astounding rate the
system's components had a chance of
actively exchanging material
at some point the supernova would have
scattered most of this material in the
space around it
while the second component would have
been ejected from the system
the star westerlund 1 5 which is located
comparatively close to the magnetar
may well have been that very component
although it is not certain
unfortunately chances of discovering any
planets in the superstar cluster
westerland one
are thin first of all the stars the
cluster is comprised of are too young
for any planets to form in their
environs
this curious process takes hundreds of
millions of years at the very least
secondly even billions of years later
when the cluster supposedly turns into a
globular one it is hardly worthwhile to
anticipate any objects to be born there
that would potentially be capable of
sustaining life the close proximity of
large and heavy stars
makes the potential planets orbits
unstable
moreover in certain circumstances a
massive neighbor
relatively close to a star system may
actually destroy it
completely besides thousands of active
stars concentrated in a small area of
space
create a remarkably powerful radiation
background
frequent flares of supernovae occurring
in this crammed space
may cause harmful gamma-ray bursts which
destroy
any life on a planet's surface chances
are that even if mankind finds a way to
cover
interstellar distances clusters will
still remain
deadly areas for quite a while
either way all these speculations don't
put a damper on the charms and beauty of
the starry heavens
the cosmos is a limitless source of
knowledge about the universe for
scientists
and a source of inspiration for artists
for all we know at some point it may
become a new home for mankind
and while this time hasn't yet come we
will just keep making new
informative episodes let's keep in touch
[Music]
[Music]
you